Welcome to the class.
We feel this course will be very beneficial for aspiring and
practicing data scientists in industry and in academia.
>> In this class, we will learn how to build and validate models.
Many of you may have already taken a course in machine learning or
data science, and may already be familiar with machine learning models.
In this course, we will take a more general approach, walking through
the questioning, modeling and validation steps of the model-building process.
Now, the goal is to get you to practice thinking in depth about a problem and
coming up with your own solutions.
Many examples we will attempt may not have a one correct answer, but
will require you to work through the problem,
applying the methods that we hope to illustrate throughout this class.
>> It is somewhat like a game of chess.
The rules are quite well-defined, but one needs to have a strategy for winning.
In any given situation, there may be multiple correct moves leading you to
victory and numerous incorrect ones.
It is to study and practice.
You learn the strategies for winning.
>> At the end of this class, you will feel confident in your ability to
conquer new problems by applying an iterative process of analysis that takes you
from a vague initial question to a rigorous model addressing it and
quantifying the uncertainty that exists in any model.
In addition, you might learn about new types of models to apply to problems, and
you will learn how to use the best model for
the task that takes the most advantage of data instead of
applying one black box model after another and hoping for the best.
But before all of that, let's get to know each other.